Dear fellow scholars.
This is two minute papers with [inaudible] neural network based learning
algorithms are on the rise these days.
And even though it is common knowledge that they are capable of image
classification, or in other words,
looking at an image and saying whether it depicts a dog or a cat
nowadays, they can do much, much more. In this series.
We covered a stunning paper that showcase the system that could not only
classify an image,
but write the proper sentence on what is going on and could cover
even highly non-trivial cases. You may be surprised,
but this thing is not recent at all.
This is four year old news insanity. Later.
Researchers turned this whole problem around and performed something that was
previously thought to be impossible.
They started using these networks to generate photorealistic images from a
written text description.
We could create new bird species by specifying that it should have orange legs
and a short, a little bit later.
Researchers at Nvidia who recognized and addressed two shortcomings.
One was that the images were not that detailed and tool,
even though we could input text,
we couldn't exert too much artistic control over the results in came
style again to the rescue,
which was able to perform both of these difficult tasks really well.
These images were progressively grown,
which means that we started out with a course image and go over it over and over
again, adding new details. This is what the results look like.
And we can Marvel at the fact that none of these people are real. However,
some of these images were still contaminated by unwanted artifacts.
Furthermore, there are some features that are highly localized.
As we exert control over these images,
you can see how this part of the teeth and eyes are pinned to a particular
position and the algorithm just refuses to let it go sometimes to the
detriment of its surroundings. This new work is titled style again, too,
and it addresses all of these problems in one go,
perhaps this is the only place on the internet where we can say that finally,
teeth and eyes are now allowed to float around freely and mean it with a
positive sentiment here, you see a few handpicked examples from the best ones.
And I have to say these are eye-popping really detailed and correct looking
images. My goodness,
the mixing examples you'll see here are also outstanding way better than the
previous version.
Also note that as there are plenty of training images out there for many other
things beyond human faces, it can also generate cars, churches,
horses, and of course, cats.
Now that the original star and one work has been out for awhile,
we have a little more clarity and understanding as to how it does what it does
and the readings and parts of the architecture have been revised and simplified.
This clarity comes with additional advantages beyond faster and higher quality
training and in his generation. For instance, interestingly, despite the,
the fact that the quality has improved significantly images made with a new
method can be detected more easily. Not that the paper was much,
much more than this.
So make sure to have a look in the video description in this series,
we always say that two more papers down the line and this technique will be
leaps and bounds beyond the first iteration. Well,
here we are not two, but only one more paper down the line.
What a time to be alive. The source code of this project is also available.
What's more, it even runs in your browser, this,
so it has been supported by weights and biases,
weights and biases provides tools to track your experiments in your deep
learning projects.
It can save you a ton of time and money in this project and is being used by an
AI Toyota research Stanford and Berkeley here,
you see a beautiful final report on one of their projects on classifying parts
of streets, images, and see how these learning algorithms evolve over time.
Make sure to visit them through when db.com/papers or just click the link,
the video description, and you can get a free demo today.
Our thanks to weights and biases for helping us make better videos for you.
Thanks for watching and for your generous support. And I'll see you next time.